bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors là si on comprend
bien
twitter va plus loin que le bannissement
de donald trump ma intervient contre des
profils qui reprennent des propos tirés
du globe du républicain oui absolument
et donc il ya deux enseignements à tirer
le premier enseignement c'est que tous
ceux qui visent de la drogue pour vérité
ne vise pas que lui même mais tout le
mouvement conservateur
c'est à dire aujourd'hui aux états unis
l'opposition politique
et puis deuxièmement ça montre quand
même que donald trump reste la
personnalité fédératrice de l'opposition
et d'un côté le parti républicain a bien
compris que pour 2022 ou pour 2024
il ne pourrait pas faire sans donner à
tron il va rester le leader du parti
républicain et on voit aujourd'hui que
le parti est en train de se fédérer
autour de lui
maintenant ce parti il fait face à des
démocrates au pouvoir et des démocrates
qui profite d'une certaine collusion je
dirais idéologique avec les médias les
médias sociaux et même aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de multinationales pour
essayer tout simplement de faire taire
l'opposition
et il faut bien comprendre une chose
c'est que il ne s'agit pas simplement du
débat d'idées mais en privant je dirais
les conservateurs et les hommes
politiques conservateurs de plateforme
au sein des maisons sociaux ce qui est
visé c'est de leur couper les faux c'est
à dire de les empêcher d'avoir le
moindre soutien financier qu'ils
puissent organiser une campagne menée
une quelconque mobilisation derrière un
candidat ou une idée donc on en revient
toujours à l'essentiel c'est-à-dire le
nerf de la guerre ce sont des décisions
qui véritablement vont à l'encontre de
tout ce qu'on peut considérer comme les
bases ou les piliers d'une démocratie et
d'un débat je dirais d'un débat
d'opinion libre alors l'ancien chef
d'état a été évincé de twitter en début
d'année pour avoir encouragé l'invasion
du capitole qui abrite le congrès là
précisément quel est le motif
mais y'en a pas le motif c'est
simplement que enfin officiellement n'y
en a pas c'est à dire qu on est toujours
sûr
ans et du précédent on accuse aussi bien
facebook d'accord qui a également
poursuivi et prolonger le bannissement
de l'ancien président on accuse
d'ailleurs trempe de perpétrer ce que
les américains appellent the big life
the big lyle le grand mensonge c'est
supposé être l'idée que l'élection
présidentielle de 2020 aurait été volé
c'est à dire qu'elle aurait été marqué
par des fraudes suffisante pour inverser
le résultat et ça c'est quand même ce
que trump a défendu tout au long de
l'automne et c'est ce qui a incité les
événements du 6 janvier
quand vous venez le rappeler maintenant
ce cas particulier dans cette idée c'est
que les républicains se plaignent que
depuis quatre ans mais aujourd'hui
depuis cinq ans c'est à dire que depuis
que dans la tron a remporté la
présidentielle de 2016 eh bien les
médias et les radios et les réseaux
sociaux ont relégué un autre gros
mensonge c'était le mensonge selon
lequel est bien l'élection de la trempe
était due à une interférence de la
russie et que son équipe de campagne
ainsi que seul administration
travaillait main dans la main avec les
services secrets russes contre l'intérêt
amérique et on sait aujourd'hui que
toutes les accusations qui ont été
portées à l'époque contre l'équipe trup
était fondé sur un dossier qui lui même
était de la désinformation donc était
totalement fausse néanmoins les médias
sociaux ne se sont jamais insurgé contre
la propagation de ce gros mensonge de ce
big lie na va savons tout simplement une
chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui aux états
unis vous avez deux poids deux mesures
vous avez un parti unique et vous avez
une tendance de plus en plus à faire en
sorte que l'opposition n'ait pas droit
au chapitre
à partir du moment où elle dit des
choses qui vont s'opposer à ce que vous
pensez et c'est vraiment l'attitude que
l'on observera par des démocrates et de
tous les alliés de toutes leurs alliés
dans les médias aussi bien dans les
médias officiels le new york times et
les autres que dans les mets ou dans les
réseaux sociaux je rappelle que facebook
par exemple pendant la campagne avait
refusé ou avaient bloqué l'accès au new
york post
quand le new york post avait mis en
avant son enquête sur le fils du
candidat et donne à l'époque ntabadde
il y avait une véritable intérêt
dans la campagne électorale n'a par des
réseaux sociaux et bien on voit
aujourd'hui la poursuite de cette
attitude si ce n'est que désormais les
réseaux sociaux sont du côté du pouvoir
et donc ils font taire l'opposition et
ça démontre également que les gaffes à 1
sont forts vents très puissants
ils sont très puissants alors on peut se
poser une question d'ailleurs on peut se
poser une question aux républicains
quand il fait pendant quatre ans pour le
démanteler ses gaffes à ce qui est
acquis aujourd'hui c'est que si en 2022
on a une aversion de la majorité les
républicains je rappelle espère quand
même reprendre la chambre des
représentants la majorité démocrate au
sein de la chambre des représentants
actuellement être extrêmement fine c'est
une demi douzaine de sièges pocus donc
les démocrates auraient des républicains
ont l'ambition de reprendre le contrôle
de la chambre des représentants à partir
de 2022 et à partir de là de contrôler
l'agenda législatif et donc de pouvoir
s'attaquer aux cafards
actuellement les gaffes à travaillent
main dans la main avec de pouvoir
démocrate il n'y a aucune volonté de la
part de ce pouvoir de de démanteler les
gaffes a par contre si les républicains
parviennent à revenir aux affaires
il est évident que ce sera fait alors
très rapidement sur un tweeter trump est
définitivement bannis sur les autres
réseaux sociaux le caractère définitif
n'a pas encore été tranchée est ce que
vous y croyez ou un ancien président qui
n'auraient pas la parole sur les réseaux
sociaux lors d'une chasse ont alors ça
l'impact est énorme
il ya eu une il ya une enquête récemment
je ne sais plus de quel institut
médiatique qui indiquait que le volume
d'attention portée à donald trump avait
baissé de 90% 90% depuis qu'il a quitté
la maison blanche et qu'il a été bannie
des réseaux sociaux
donc en gros ils ont réussi à le faire
taire il a 10 % de 2,2 les coudes qu'il
avait précédemment dont l'impact est
énorme par contre saintes à pâtes qu'il
est aussi mobilisateur dans le camp de m
il est mobilisateur pour sa base qui se
sent persécuté et qui se voit persécutés
tous les jours donc je pense que ce type
de comportement
ça consiste aussi uss a également pour
effet je dirais de renforcer
l'opposition et on en verra les
conséquences ou pas lors du prochain
scrutin
l'échéance véritablement novembre 2022
et les élections intermédiaires
olivier merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur alips merci merci